three wins his third win came against
these tampa bay rays however
just went five innings he's got
tremendous bullpen help
to two pitch swinging a miss by lyle and
a good first inning
for sean manaya well our starting
pitchers are presented by baycare and
tonight for the tampa bay rays is going
to be left-handed rich hill
making his seventh start of the season
the record one and one era 639 and 25 in
the third innings
of work bottom of the first nothing
nothing
murphy against hill relegated to doing
lately
but you can't really blame them here's a
swing and a comebacker hill falls down
as he catches it
and bounces the throw to first that
yandi diaz scoops up
he is out the inning is over and rich
hill
the oldest player in the game now with
pull holes not active fell onto his left
hip
thankfully that hip held together so
lead off man aboard for the second
inning in a row here's jed lowry
that one's gonna drop into center field
for a base hit
so the 80s have two on nobody out here
in the bottom of the second
here's tony kemp
there's a liner down to first caught by
diaz off the bat of kemp two men left
kevin kiermaur leads it off adamus to
follow and then phillips
left right left against sean manaya
so outside corner strike three call
[Applause]
that's what you're gonna miss by adamus
and that is four strikeouts for sean
manning
yeah he's feeling that elevated heat
missile right here
he swings to a curve comes away empty
and shaw manaya
has just caved to side he's got five
through three innings
pitchers duel so far between mania and
rich hill
no score top of the fifth andy diaz mike
brasso mike zanino
he four five and six hitters
bounce toward alva sanders who charges
throws
and that's out number one
gonna miss strikeout number six
for sean now the 1-1 delivery and that
swung out of blooped over short back is
elvis he's going to get there and short
left
and he makes the catch and sean banaya
perfect through five
innings on this friday night both of
these pitchers have been sharp you know
rich hillary does have the hit batter
and a couple of walks but when he's
needed to make [ __ ]
he has done just that been helped out by
a double play ball
and the number nine hitter tony kemp
and the curveball gets him
pop-up foul ball a lot of room
diaz there to make the catch and it's a
one two three inning
this top of the sixth inning there's no
score and mania has not allowed a base
runner
hits a high fly ball to right biscotti
circles underneath it and that's the
first half
0-2 to willy adams quick miss
struck him out seven strikeouts for
mania
well he's very efficient and i think
that says it all right there
owen two let it go thomas
tells you right there type of pitch it
was
strike three called outside corner
manaya is dealing folks
sean manaya has been perfect for six
innings nobody on here comes
matt olson and he pulls it and a
dive to come up with that when diaz
beats him
to the bag diaz guarding that line
came up with it and then the race was on
that's
what the shift allows you to do
everybody thinks it's the second base
about the outfield yes he plays a role
but the shift allows you
to play your first baseman closer to the
line to take away
a sure extra base hit in a game like
this
that is large here's murphy a homart
against hill at tropicana field in the
first pitch center of the air towards
shallow left
coming on hard is margot slides and
makes the catch
six shutout innings for hill six perfect
innings for mania
we've got ourselves quite a duel no
score it is the top of the seventh
inning
as sean manaya goes back to work tampa
bay rays still looking for their first
base runner here's a 3-1
and that's outside ball four and a
rosarena becomes the first base runner
for tampa bay any stretches and deals
left on left allow
high in the air right center hit pretty
well piscotty back
biscotti near the wall piscotty up
against the wall grabs it
it was such a high fly ball but scotty
had time to get back there and
kind of gauge himself he knew he was
close to the wall but he knew he also
had just enough room
now jed lowry bats
in the air toward left center still in
the air
kiermeier turns around and bangs off the
wall
and lowry's gonna have a double
three hits for the a's they all belong
to jed lowry
so here's brown go ahead run at second
base
with one out brown base head right
center field
lowry's get around third he's gonna
score in the eighth take a one-nothing
lead
well that changes everything gentlemen
yes it does
sir shamania seven no hit innings and
now a one-nothing lead
there's a shot and that's going to be
the first hit and it's going to go all
the way to the wall and deep right
center field
brasso is going to have a lead-off
double here in the top of the eighth
so sean manaya got through seven innings
of no hit baseball runner at second
nobody out
go win the game celino in the batter's
box
that's a lighter in the center of base
head
rosso heads to the plate and this game
is tied
mike cenino comes through and the rays
make it a 1-1 ball game
so it is the bottom of the ninth of a
1-1 game seth brown who pinched it and
drove in
the a's only running
that baby is gone brown
walks off the rays and the a's win a
fabulous game over tampa bay the final
the a's
two and the raise one